[Applause]
hello hello everyone welcome to GameSpot
live I'm Persia and today I'm joined
with man vs game V man vs game the man
vs game don't get it twisted always get
it right all right so today we are gonna
be playing some days gone and today's
stream is sponsored by days gone so I'm
pretty excited to check out the action
we've gotten a little bit into the game
we're kicking off from one of the first
main missions from Copeland's camp so
right this beautiful beautiful game yes
and we don't have a lot of time we're
just jumping right into it you just want
to see the the gameplay by the way audio
good we can hear me okay okay bring up a
little bit more game sound here so you
know the audio the visuals in this game
very beautiful you know motorcycles and
free currents I got it
which I don't know I've only been able
to spend a little bit of time with the
game and it is very interesting how I
know it seems like a game that you could
definitely get lost this isn't a goddamn
bike oh god oh yes this is a mature
stream today [__] yeah so if they can
swear I could swear exactly
by the way it's uh it is it's good to be
here thanks for having me by the way
thanks for joining us we're very excited
to have you when they first told us that
you're gonna come in to play with us I
was like yes this is awesome so I'm
really looking forward to it and
hopefully you guys are looking forward
to seeing some gameplay like we said we
don't have too much time today but we've
jumped forward a little bit here to get
to this point
you know we saw a little bit of how they
ended up here this story takes place two
years after pretty much a
post-apocalyptic have been so right that
I am very curious of stare Lake you know
how the whole outbreak happens of course
we're not gonna be giving away like like
while I was talking I was like Deacon
please yeah now I got a follows the road
here my god right viewers watching
you're like you hired this guy well the
bike is tricky tricky and on top of that
at this point in the story you know the
beginning was a little bit tutorial but
Deacon had his own bike he's the main
character and then you know some you
know like bugs basically stole it from
him while he was attending to other
business right so now he has to use this
you know piece of crap bike right and
then we're just kind of like rebuilding
now exactly oh we kind of had a taste of
what it's like to have a good bike and
now we're using this hunk of metal that
we're stuck with the crap yeah so I'm
gonna jump off we've got freaker's in
the area yes even right now you know
we've left Oakland and I have like
completely forgotten what I'm doing so
far - hold on get the wheel out l2 is to
aim that's the male a wet oh my god hold
on r1 to roll and we have you know a bar
bottom left the little blue bar above
that is your stamina meter so man you
gotta keep your eye on that meter
because once you run out of stamina
you're gonna have a hard time running
away from the freaker's right and
stamina is very important from what I've
found yes you know wait let me grab I
always want to be scavenging yes which I
liked how fluid scavenging was like it
didn't seem like it took up a lot of
time yeah we do
of convenient little things that you
might not think about like for example
you have three or four items in one spot
and instead of running up to each one
holding square holding square holding
square it'll let you scoop them all up
in one go which you know something small
but when you're playing and you're
running from freaker's and you need to
pick up something quick that's real Oh
bro reload ammo I am out of ammo now so
now is the time when you pull out your
trusty melee weapon home improvement yes
and let's see if we can get that going
douche oh right in the face
oh yeah so all of your melee weapons
they have a durability meter so you can
only use them so many times before they
break yes but you've all you've always
got your trusty boot knife which I like
it's invincible exactly it's it's the
weakest melee weapon but it is
invincible
let's see melee weapons found in the
field break easily in combat make sure
you pay attention to the weapon
durability meter exactly like I did not
there if there's a blinking red icon
there's only a few hits left before it
breaks got it got it and the knife is
gonna hopefully do us just fine brutal
juicy
yeah extra juicy Oh swarmer ears so
those specific freaker's are called
swarmers but there are different types
as well you have screamers and they
basically call all the homies they just
yell out into the world that they call
though you know they make the hordes
happen so you have to watch out for them
and then you know we got I forgot what
the other ones called wait let me turn
to my trusty notes here Gary I want to
say I'm still getting it you know
familiarized with the controls okay I
was just asked what am i doing here on
this mission what's so specifically this
mission the cool thing about this game
is that there are a lot of missions side
missions storyline missions so on and so
forth so this is a Nero camp okay
which obviously government-related to
some extent so we know that there's
useful stuff here so now we got to try
to get inside of it but it's man you
know it's all automated
so now we have to fix the generator just
to get the thing open
so our generator right here okay it's
fuel okay now I'm putting it together
Wow see this is I need the information
here actually the information is easy
you also have a little bit of a called
survivor mode which is like Detective
Mode that you're gonna press in on r3
and that will kind of let you know what
you need to look for the little
triangles tell you where important
interactable things are - yes usually a
lot of like scrap things to scavenge
things you can interact with doors - or
dead bodies you can scavenge from let's
see if I know we need the fuel did I not
grab the fuel I thought I grabs you good
okay this games pretty realistic - which
is really fun so you can look towards
maybe big trucks or something that might
have a gas can in the back of it or but
like a really obvious so maybe you can
check like I don't know the back of a
tow truck and there's also fuel stations
throughout the map that you can actually
drive your bike up to and pump some gas
so you have to take good care of your
bike if you get stranded without your
bike GG's this was what and that never
happened to me in the time that I was
playing but that was the first time that
I've actually refueled anything that's
exciting let's try starting it now and
we have power prime it oh we have we
have power which also means the alarm
system wearing so of course we got a
climb up to the roof you disable these
speakers oh my god
let's because don't forget you don't
have any no ammo yeah this is a great
spot you left me Persia okay so we got
one megaphone down survival him turn off
the things attractive as well yeah for
the love of God the freaker's are on
their way
okay okay donk alright we're safe now
okay beautiful by the way hello thank
you everybody for joining us here today
with a special GameSpot live edition
featuring me man versus game in the
studio sponsored by days gone and
something that I think is really
interesting with this game that I feel
is done very well is the the weather
cycles and like the day/night cycles
because the weather and you know the
time of day actually affects the
freaker's you know they're stronger at
night but that's where they like that's
when they like to hibernate
so there will will be less of them
they're just a little bit stronger I
don't remember how the cold affects them
but you know time of day and weather I
do have an effect on the Freaker so you
guys keep that in mind to here and there
you'll find beds that you can sleep in
which team like change the time of day
okay that'll help you if you're like man
I don't want to fight them when they're
strong I want to be daytime just take a
nap and then go back out into the world
I want to say Gary again I'm gonna dress
you your comments I don't know why I'm
just I'm drawn in like a hawk to your
comments if Deacon seems like he's
moving slow it's because I the player in
moving very slow I'm just trying to keep
the conversation going
yeah oh so this is what's super
important about these neuro cams so you
get to choose what do we level up do we
want more health do we want more stamina
or do we want more focus what's say you
viewer at home yeah viewers what should
we what should we go for so obviously
health great choice you can take a few
more hits the stamina though we've
already talked about how important it is
if you can't run away from the freaker's
and you have no ammo it's gonna be tough
yeah and you also use stamina meter when
you roll enrolling super important to
dodge all that crazy damage so that's
also a plus too however focus lets you
slow things down so you can make every
bullet count which you know has a lot of
use in it in of its own and am I crazy
or like because I was trying to do the
focus shot earlier no you probably don't
have it yet yeah
I'm level the focus if that's if that's
cool with everybody focus is fantastic
look at this we're finally getting the
answers in stamina health health I've
already chosen I'm sorry there's a bit
of a delay hey
to be fair I leveled up stamina but
focus is very important because there
are wild crazy animals in this game also
the wolves they're fast even if you're
on your motorcycle and sometimes you
need that focus shot but you might
notice this idea it requires a focus
shot skill so the cool thing about this
game is that your touchpad is also
integrated into what you do yes so you
can like swipe right to go the map swipe
down to go to your skills right oh maybe
we should show them how to equip a skill
let's do that wipe down there you go
boom we got the skills and we have one
skill point because Copelan gave us one
for finishing our first mission that you
guys did not see what I got yes get into
that when playing the game so you get
three different categories right your
range combat your melee combat and then
survivable so let's open up the survival
did I think that's where the focus is in
is it survival I thought it was ranged
yeah I think it's ranged combat got this
there we go you are the man vs game
that's right I got the info all right
focus shots yes so that's what we want
to equip so that we can actually use our
newly buffed focus shot which I'll okay
so while aiming l2 left trigger press r3
to activate focus yes I did have it
correct okay I had it right guys so now
we're ready to actually use the focus
shot we have more time to use the focus
shot because you'll see once he uses it
there's a little meter next year reticle
that drains as you're focusing some yes
and for me I don't know like aiming with
an analog stick it's just anything that
can help you out there's is very much
appreciated especially here where
obviously ammo is scarce and every
headshot does count
you know these figures do die too
headshots unless they're the abnormal
like super tanky ones like
breakers that's gonna be a little bit
more in down the storyline but like we
said there's a little bunch of different
types of zombies freaker's Freaker that
free right right not zombies the
freaker's oh this is something else I
really love about this game too and
that's just because you know I'm weird
but there's a pretty cool crafting
system in this game I like that yes the
what was that that I was making crossbow
bolts yes and I loved how I was like
cutting down sapling trees for the wood
it's so realistic yeah yeah I really
like the attention to detail on that
alright that man is in a GameSpot HQ and
I'm sorry I keep getting distracted guys
I always want to look at the chat it's
like a habit for me at this point like I
just have to look at the the chat and by
the way if you want to like totally
backseat me and tell me like where I
need to be going just to keep action
moving please feel free basically where
we are in the story right now we
mentioned we saw a little bit of
backstory leading up to this you know
post-apocalyptic world but our homey
Boozer right he's our right-hand man he
got basically kidnapped by some crazy
people and they burned up his arms oh my
god wrong I was trying to roll I can't
believe what in the hell
so r1 okay okay I got a I got a I got a
heal up this is an absolute disaster why
didn't he just scratch your back
why let's just go with a knife then I
guess I mean my god this is such a
mistake
oh Lord how about we just run to the
bike okay let's just run to the bike and
get out of Dodge no I really I was
relying on you Persia am I out of
healing stuff can I not cry
you might hat scratch so I'll hold down
r1 okay oh this is l1 o l1 there we go I
see you're getting terrible advice here
r1 to craft I'm gonna grab our two to
use there you know luckily we picked up
some utensils actually use it oh my god
here I I wanted to take this guy out I
want to take out at least one
oh he's tough he's a tough guy yeah he
seems heavily mutated for sure okay well
the boot knife is pretty weak but it
doesn't break so that's the give and
take care right
which is this favorite miss fair so yeah
basically our man boozers injured we
gotta help him out he's all we got in
this lonely lonely world so we've
infiltrated this narrow camp we've
retrieved the sterile bandages and now
we need to go back to boozer and drop
off the goods yes and helping with that
arm
there we go Jesus so there are two
things to keep track of just generally
besides this gasps you know you have to
repair it with scraps if it starts to
get damaged Oh
stabbed right through this boom crack it
and we've got another ear so the ears
are kinda like currency you take them to
the camps you turn them in and you get
credits to spend at each can that's
right the bounties are done please get
on the bikes or quicker picker uppers
there we go and that's one thing about
the bike at this game is like every time
you hit something it's going to inflict
damage your bike is smoking hot not in a
good way right now so this is really bad
I I almost feel like purrs you should
just take the controller like rip the
controller out of my hands and then I'll
just blather on I didn't like that
implication if we need to know we're
pretty close we're getting there okay
Boozer I'm coming we've got the yes we
got pretty good luck all right we are in
routes by the way mankind it's good to
see you guys on YouTube it's crazy it is
crazy being over here yeah thanks for
joining us I feel a little naughty all
right yes unfortunately everyone at home
does have to wait until Friday because
that is when the game is being released
April 26 a couple of days and again I
just want to give this disclaimer
I am trying to play this game is to the
best of my ability but I'm still it's
much more difficult than it looks
I'm well and I'm going on very little
sleep and I'm just been so used to
playing like other games have been
coming out lately anyway you know what
I'm gonna stop with the John's I'm gonna
stop with the excuses here we go we've
made it to the encampment yes so square
to get off everybody should I mean take
it to the fuel and you have five scrap
so I think if you like it takes like max
ten scrap what fix your bike there's
fuel here to the left or you could pull
the bike up to those those barrels and
you can fuel it that way okay okay here
we go
let's fill it up fueling up the bike
then we'll work on the smoke yes
billowing out just press circle again
200 circle again - what to repair oh
okay okay
luckily universal bike fix it button
would you get off the bike please yeah
thank you okay
so certainly again to fix and then you
look in the bottom left you're using the
scrap that you have to fix the bike so
boom 100% dude is like he has definitely
read Zen in the art of motorcycle repair
so please let's go alright
oh actually we got to go see boos he's
at the top of the tower where the hell
am i okay jeez for the love of crime
please get off the bike okay there we go
hello Mike now for you guys at home he
gets to meet Boozer for the first time
what a guy he's been in better shape but
you know what he's been by our side the
last two years and how can you not love
a guy named Boozer exactly all right
shitty arm oh no this is exactly where I
left off with the story everybody I want
to say the motion capture and the acting
it's pretty good it's funny growing up
in Montana I went to high school with
like I was surrounded by guys that look
just like deacon
excuse me Duncan it is vegan okay you
just grab some of this coffee here boy
I could sure use some caffeine so yeah
boom we've finished the first mission
still lots to do but you know this is a
part of multiple storylines we're gonna
run into actually so that's pretty cool
too and each mission gives you XP so as
you level up you'll get more skill
points and then you also have to be
mindful of leveling up your experience
per camp which is called trust right so
and I love that aspect of the game the
way there are different camps different
factions that you can kind of you know
get in bed with and get you play both
sides exactly and each camp you built a
different trust level towards so it's
really important to kind of manage that
equally because you only get access to
certain things that you can buy within
each camp if you're at a certain trust
level so if you want to level up or add
nos to your bike and you have to have a
level 2 trust well now you have to
either collect swarm arrears and turn in
the bounties finish missions help
hostages who are like trapped by saunas
freaker's and then send them to a camp
and you'll get like trust that way too
so there's a bunch of different cool
ways to do it
now this this concerns me a storyline
he's my brother 12% the goal is I have
to keep Boozer alive so much she's last
two years well shall we continue yes the
part I don't think we want to get too
much into like how the game starts out
like that's and of course very very
special thank you to D is gone for
sponsoring today's stream and helping us
you know get to play some of this
beautiful game with you guys use an idea
let me see if we have any guns in the
the gun locker I love this primary we
have 0 primary weapons that's hopeful
but as you go out into the world and
collect things you can come and put them
in these lockers or you know check out
what you have we only have you know
limited amount things right now cuz it's
still early but you can come here and
fill up your ammo when you need to it
does cost credit so you also have to
make sure your credits are fulfilled at
each camp because your credit amount is
also different at each camp too so if
you have like 5,000 credits at
Copeland's you might have like a hundred
credits somewhere else and just to make
sure that is 84 credits not 84 cents in
the apocalypse era like the same thing
does it matter yeah what what is the
economy even mean in zombie apocalypse
this is a theoretical currency there
you'll get in the crossbow now this I
was all about the crossbow earlier and
later on down the road as you're
leveling up your skills you can actually
go pick up your bows after you shoot
them which is something you can't do off
off jump so particularly Boozer don't
ignore me
alright I was just checking to see if he
had anything else to say he's resting
yeah he's just he's had a big day
yeah he had a rough time cranky too
obviously yeah I almost tried to blow
our heads off with a shotgun and so and
I keep forgetting to run people are
saying like you
it looks like he's move slowed it's just
me moving slow
exactly that's and that's the blue bar
okay so all right so now we have our new
objective obviously we see it at the top
left of our screen locate the Cascade
radio tower ambush cam so obviously we
have the Freaker story about but like in
many you know Polk post-apocalyptic
settings humans are just as dangerous
which that to me is the main draw to the
the zombie apocalypse you know setting
its you know they're surrounded by these
freakish you know inhuman monsters but
then you know in most stories you know
it turns out that like the humans
actually become far more you know evil
sometimes they do far more terrible
things to their own kind here we go i
watch this drift bringer
okay that was lame that was a lame drift
hold on I want to do a good drift here
circle yes which I actually I had gotten
it okay here we go all right so wait
hold up before you close there because
now we're going into the ambush cam oh
my god and so they'll see you so all I
think they've already seen that's fine
that's fine okay I guess we're just
gonna run straight in okay we've got
plenty of ammo now yes and I think
there's also I've got the focus mode
it's cool I think there's another weapon
here on the table looks like an assault
rifle add it to the to the image there
you go to the Arsenal
what's up our Arsenal what about these
decisions decisions
a sawed-off
oh let's ask the chat really quick you
got like two seconds I know the delay is
ladies oh man hold on let me grab the
the Healy stuff here yeah always be
scavenging we are a 65 percent help oh
you know what I'm taking this I'm
staking the shotgun and we are pulling
it out Oh God
oh my god no I don't let her gun but you
like this that's fine this is fine oh my
god I just noticed my health is bad
vicious bushes are huge yourself aspect
why okay I was gonna say why am I not
healing up okay okay okay now if you
look in your bottom right next to your
map you'll see that there's a little
eyeball and there's an X over it right
now when you crouched in the bushes it
gives you some stealth and then you'll
also see a little microphone icon which
will let you know how much noise you're
making around everybody so we're hiding
now this bush is you know invisibility
cloak and now we have some time to heal
up use them bandages crafts something oh
that's right let's craft some more
bandages if we can dear lord thank you
and you'll notice like you picked up the
AR and then you picked up the ammo and
then you picked up the sawed off and
there was nothing like you had no ammo
so those decisions or like you pick
between the gun and pick up the ammo or
small but important like bureaucratic
you like now you may have noticed
because if you didn't notice Oh
saved by Mother Nature uh what's the aim
fall off I love how the detail with like
all the weapons all the systems all at
work in this game so crossbow bolts
affected by gravity it will drop as they
travel to their target when shooting is
something far away aim higher to make
sure your bolts hit their mark brilliant
okay so we have cleared two out of ten
you you might be able to creep up on him
and do like a stealth attack uh oh it's
fine yeah he's just a wall
I don't want to waste a bolt on him that
was the thing yeah and you might miss
because there when they get close to you
they get a little like okay get some
ammo in it oh my god
Oh God we're matched and we're mashing
okay that's what the grab really beat
them up oh man okay and there goes Wow
we're fine we're fine
there we go and then also animals you
can scavenge me off of and solve that -
the kitchen's within the camp's to get
some extra credits the game goes dpo we
have eight more goons take off right now
now we got the aka
I think you need to reload they oh I
need to get serious now I want yeah yeah
oh okay
this is actually one of my favorite
things you can hit up on the d-pad to
bring up your binoculars and then you
can mark the enemies so the cool thing
about marking them not only do you know
where they are obviously but you know
when they're on to you
so obviously the gray is they're
suspicious but they don't know anything
yet it will turn yellow when they're
like he's over there I know exactly for
sure and then the red diamond around is
their health bar so you'll see as you
start hitting them or if ya headshot
them in one go they just die that's what
I'm talking about baby
okay finally I'm really trying to like
up my game play here cuz I know it's
been pretty atrocious up until now we
are sponsored by these gone after all
they might as you might want to make a
game look decent okay alright well no
sneak up on him that's a well ouch
walking really slow makes your footsteps
stealthy triangle I don't know is it
dude I just I can't get over the brutal
violence in video games I mean it is
pretty glorious I'm not getting a chance
to use like the fire axes and stuff
sorry get some for anybody who has not
caught on yet Persia is definitely the
experts between the two of us here like
I've barely you know had enough time to
check out the game but hey you're going
a total different direction I did which
is kind of the cool thing about this
game is that they throw a mission at you
and you can go about it self elite you
know pick them off one by one or you
could just Rambo it up and rely on your
your aim and your focus just in time
that meter was almost out I like
watching girls like this is pathetic
it's like wavering around wrong don't
you dare there you go already got her
let's check out the corpse here get some
ammo
some blammo and you pick up some
resources he had two rags on him what
are you using them for boy she had a
pipe bomb she was she was she was joking
about she was burning you up well I'm
glad she's dead
alright assault rifle ammo nice always
need that and we still got some par-3 we
can see how many more bodies we got to
catch four more all right where did you
see that Oh once we get yeah yeah so six
out of ten clear that oh okay open the
top left okay yes just a little bit of
math three guys alright
rolling through this camp on 50% oh oh
oh
let's just get in there oh and they're
gonna hold on hold on we'll just close
the door that's fine all right heal up
so you can use the map it'll tell you
which direction they're coming from Oh
all right and it's bright out there it
is and do I have my flashlight on what
am i doing there we go
I'll fight light with light where did
this person go left but you'll see on
your map like you see how it's kind of
highlighted in front of you which
general area the enemy is inside yeah
can you use that as a reference yeah
it's probably hiding probably oh yeah
was that not use X while you're aiming
down to switch sides so if you're aiming
down and you're like I don't want to
look over your right shoulder you just
hit X and health like switches stands
right okay is this easy mode I hope this
isn't easy is the normal mode okay okay
not advanced but it's normal I was when
I was playing a bit at home I was
playing on hard mode and the ankle
weights are off the death came quickly
in hard mode I will say that like you
don't get much not many chances to screw
up okay I'm moving so slowly through
this game whatever let's go come on all
right search this corpse and they are
thank God for small miracles okay and he
is out there yeah there's one outside
the gate there's one more guy still
inside the compound also oh you can
actually climb over a lot of different
types of things candy because you can
climb faster than free cruise cans a
good way to run away or you know lose
them a little bit oh yeah oh yeah okay
let's try this real quick
l1 and throw a rock somewhere we'll do
it next time but you know rocks to
distract people and then sneak up on
them and like assassinate him which is
awesome I was gonna say I'm gonna
mention I've been playing a lot of
psyche Oh shadows died twice lately
and I absolutely love it but the stealth
in the game is like questionable at best
sometimes like you're like standing
almost right in front of a character and
like he won't notice you I was impressed
just now with the stealth system at this
game when the guy actually saw me
because I was ducked behind that sort of
like work desk there or whatever the
workbench and he saw me yeah in sec you
know that would not happen Angry Bush
and you're crouching they can generally
see you like if you just hide behind
this log or something unless you're
actually 100% out of sight then you
don't have to but yeah that's pretty
good and they'll run to where you are at
all times or the last location that they
saw you at which is pretty cool so it's
not like you can just camp it out this
guy he hasn't even been paying attention
to everyone getting dropped I think he's
like given up on life I mean which can
absolutely happen in a zombie apocalypse
like eight of his people went down and
he's just chillin I think he watched it
happened and then he was just like
exactly he was like you know what just
do it just get it over with man once you
finally clear out these ambush camps
most of them will have like a secret
bunker somewhere that you can read so I
think that's the next action item the
lawnmower machine any machete it's a
lawn mower machete dude now I just need
to find a hockey mask and then we'll
have the Jason Voorhees cosplay ready to
go all right let's go
just so you're aware at home you can
click the left analog stick to run it
does you stamina but is it something I
should be remembering to do all the time
yes thank you guys so much for joining
yes we are just playing some days gone
which comes out this Friday
make sure you pre-order there are a lot
of bonuses available
oh that's sweater see I was still on the
Jason Voorhees thing it looks like Jason
Voorhees mother's sweater Jason you know
and I'm sorry we I just missed all of
that dialogue like if you're gonna kill
if you had bullets here kill me already
and then he's like you look you have a
code I only shoot women if I have to and
then you let her go huh Wow even in the
zombie apocalypse right yeah exactly
gee Arthur thank you very much for the
sub what do you guys have any questions
about the game game comes out August
April 26 Lord
sir I'm gonna let you do the talking now
well in that case this stream was
brought to you by days gone obviously
that's why we are playing it honestly
I'd play it regardless because it's been
very fun it is a full experience and
there's just a lot to chew on in this
game you know you have skills you have
multiple storylines it is a lot to take
in and for me is I'm a little
overwhelmed at the moment let's see one
of our viewers gray fox says how long is
the campaign that is a good question
there's a lot to do but you know we have
had some people not this play like get
to 40 hours and still not be done yet
there really is just
much to do and definitely worth playing
especially if you like having you know
many different aspects to look after
whether it be your bike whether it be
you know your ammunition your health
your crafting obtaining recipes to craft
different storylines side missions
leveling up you're trusting your credit
per campe
everything it's really cool and you know
I've only obtained a few crafting
recipes for melee weapons but once you
do start getting those you get to make
some cool stuff you know like you'll get
a regular bat in a box and nails
that's what now you have a spiked bat it
does more damage it's pretty cool so I
want to say I'm appreciating the the
view up here yeah so this area that
we're in this is based on Oregon is it
not and like in the game okay which I
like the one thing that really I anybody
who's watched my stream anybody who's
heard me talk they know I really am not
much of a multiplayer kind of guy is
there anything I need to do up here by
the way um not right now no yeah we
should know went up there preemptively
but it's fine
yes what am i pad to enjoy the view okay
can we zoom down no ladders which is
true yeah there's a lot of love depths
excuse me depth I kind of like that it's
realistic because you know you know some
games you just have too much of
everything and if you really think about
it this was actually two years after an
event it would be pretty hard to find a
lot of things so I kind of liked that
aspect of it makes a little bit more
difficult you have to be a little bit
more practical with how you kill
freaker's and stuff now for me
personally I spent a lot of time you
know being sneaky and going for the
stealth kills just to save ammo and
usually it's a OneTouch kill like every
time you sneak up on someone anyways so
it also saves time hordes on the other
hand which I have never run into I have
yet to run into them okay here we go
chance we are investigating this bunker
we mentioned it earlier whenever you
clear out an ambush camp there's
probably a bunker that has some goodies
in it so that's what we're going to
check out and now we're going down yeah
CID on okay I won't Wow
now the Fall Out Boy it was sooo easy
can you all believe I actually made it
into the bunker like are we all not
totally amazed with my my gameplay
prowess yes about ready for you to just
rip the controller out of my hands there
we go oh here's where we get to make the
spiked bat but one cool thing to note if
you are gonna pick up another melee
weapon it will tell you if it's good or
bad or what's better or worse about it
than the one you currently have so well
no we want to make a spiked bat we do
beautiful obtained what we needed from
this bunker nice we've got some
experience and we've got some trust
building trust with Copeland's you bring
it to me do you can you hear me me and
boozer can't ride north until I fix up
his bike get some better gear alright
beautiful and now we've unlocked a
recipe which is for that spike Tibet a
beautiful okay look at that that's nasty
okay convenient box of nails we've found
which I just noticed you saw it up there
before before I grabbed the recipe you
couldn't pick it out I was wondering I
didn't see a symbol I was like what what
nails so now we can craft it much like
we craft the bandages and others
shenanigans
what am i I just straight-up blanked out
there you go the melee there you go and
I do like this wheel the wheel is very
handy it is and it slows down the game a
little bit so you can kind of craft and
use things when you're getting rushed
down by freaker's right
you don't have an infinite amount of
time you know what let's take a little
nappy-poo I could use some rest
why are you not resting fool rest
sleeping use a bunk at safe locations
like bunkers or the safe house to sleep
and advance time some challenges like
infestations can be approached
differently depending on time of day
additionally progress can be saved when
near a bunk beautiful that seems like a
very risky thing to do to just an
underground bunker that we didn't close
the hatchet on but for the sake of this
bunker it was safe and I guess you know
you could only stay on edge for so long
you know like he's been in this zombie
apocalypse now for you know a couple
years right if you get started we can
see exactly how many days oh yeah 736
days he's been in this apocalypse that's
a long time
that is so he's pretty jaded to it all
he's like you know what I am just gonna
pass he's just like the hell out ya
Boozer thank you is it your other right
I'm gonna say that was my left tensions
are growing here in the GameSpot studio
all right let me just grab this too many
rags because the rags are used for a few
different items I think it's like
molotovs which I love those for the
nests filthiness we haven't come across
one yet but in various places of the map
i'll see now you have to go to the top
now they show me okay I love that it's
nightfall now yeah we did sleep so that
does change the time day it's beautiful
- that is a big beautiful sky what the
hell was that was that an alien being
okay oh no I think it was like a pine
needle oh yeah
I want to go through rifle because we're
going up here please go up yes yes all
right let her go yes this is a
PlayStation 4 exclusive we are taking
this long I thought I was supposed to go
up here now yes okay okay you made me
feel it this time because he gets the
top and he's just gonna be so tired
here we go oh yeah look at the O'Leary
mountains safehouse I'm not controlling
though so B's he's gonna string seems
like we have to kind of rein it in ya
knows language wise you know try to keep
it pg-13 ish but of course the
characters like official Boozer radioed
it and we've confirmed it some people
are trying to ambush our camp so now we
gotta go take them out all for the bro
we've got a key Boozer alive remember
and yeah Boozer you do feel for him
because of what happens to him prior to
where we started out in the game for
this stream sound like engines rip right
says how big is in the map it is massive
I've been playing for a little bit now
and I'm still nowhere near uncovering
every section of the map and there are a
lot of missions and things to fulfill
before you even get a chance to go on
the missions and the other parts of the
map so definitely a lot of time will be
invested into this game but nowadays
like that's a beautiful thing you know
they've taken a lot of time into
crafting this whole world in this
experience so I enjoyed I think it's
very well done I am wondering what I
should do with my new skill points
decisions decisions
see so I'm looking in the melee skills
section kill smaller enemies after
successfully escaping from a grapple
that seems okay what about the range
fight and flight move and aim a ranged
weapon with more precision that would be
handy or survival this feels like I'm
probably gonna want some of this
I for detail increases the time that
icons display in survival vision plants
are displayed on the mini-map oh and
thorn in your side provides a chance to
retrieve some bolts Oh crossbow that's
awesome I probably go with that since
you're using the crossbow right now yes
I would like to use it more mastered
ammo scarce and to me that's probably
the perk of using a crossbow in this
apocalypse is that you can get your
ammunition back I wanna say this is not
West Virginia this game takes place in
Oregon yes hit that word on trail we
don't catch it there we go
brand new skill learns now we gotta go
take out these people pests pestering
Boozer that's right the Marauders the
attackers we got to get back to the bike
though this is where I was going oh my
god back to the bike I'm someone in the
shots I
I barely know Gary said massive might be
a bad thing in terms of the math well it
might but not in this case because once
you clear out infestation areas which
have multiple nests then you open up the
path to fast travel so you can fast
travel to the map to areas that you've
cleared from infestation zones and you
know travel a little bit faster kind of
cut out the time you need so you know
drive from point to point but it does
take a little bit of effort to safe in
it up a little bit so definitely massive
you have options to counteract long
travel but it's gonna take some work so
did you see that drift oh this is fine
it's fine it's like this could have gone
hopefully we're not flooding the engine
okay I shouldn't have gone for that
drift I think that was a bad idea just
take it easy yeah guys I should have
been hammering on that run button the
whole time okay but yeah just a heads up
because today's stream is sponsored by
days gone so thank you again you guys
for allowing us to get our hands on this
beautiful game yeah well and thank you
for yeah letting me be part of it
honestly it's been pretty fun again I
definitely prefer single-player games
you know I definitely I can get down on
some multiplayer stuff but oh god
fight or flight what is this now
sometimes the best strategy is to run
away it's to because if you only have a
little bit of stamina left you might
need it to get away especially cuz the
hordes the words are so unforgiving I
can't even imagine like what I like you
know what you would do in that situation
feels like I would pee my pants
make your peace alright so we've located
the camp this would not be just smooth I
keep trying to drift just so you're all
aware this is fine I love how I'm just
driving right into the camp like Rambo
style you can also turn off your bike
light with the same flashlight button
which makes you a little more stealthy
too and other upgrades for your bike
later down the road you can make oh okay
okay that's enough don't show up with a
2x4 it's a spiked bat fight okay okay
the guns so why why did I put down oh my
god
this is so embarrassing um I want to get
out as a rifle this is probably a very
bad idea but here we go
focus boom oh you still got me again
we're in yes we got to seven more we got
to down seven we're in a gun beautiful
we can get them we're gonna get is this
RPG heavy I would say I mean it feels
like they're I don't know if I would say
like there are builds you can go for but
you can definitely well let's just take
a quick in a sense if you choose like
just level up all of your melee combat
or your range combat or your survival
you know that's right there's not like
skill trees but you can focus on you
know like close range
long range and of course to unlock the
next tier it requires a certain amount
of skills to be unlocked in the previous
tier so you know baby steps so there you
can absolutely have a build yeah I guess
now realizing that but it is definitely
very much like a survival game with all
the crafting and required sleeping oh
yeah the other cool thing if you notice
two people just went down so sometimes
the freaker's will run into the camp and
kill them too also so it's like they're
just as much as you're fighting against
the bad guys and freaker's they are -
they're fighting against you and
freaker's as well so sometimes you can
you know kind of make zombies run into
the camp like you go pick up a few like
stragglers and then run towards the camp
and then throw a pipe bomb or something
and they'll follow the bomb and then now
you have some some freaker's in their
camp some assists that is really cool
why don't I just get rid of the the
rifle as well guys you heard ten minutes
and you're like what lose my freaking
mind I know and also you were like
forget that ambush camp all right I'm
running back I'm running back but at
least when you go back
it's still the same amount of people
dead whole it doesn't reset or anything
like that person would you like to play
for just a little bit okay let's watch
watch how embarrassing this is going to
be for me now because perfect how much
time did you say you've spent playing
the game few days I spent like a few
hours and then oh yes I like to mark my
look at this I know I have a few left
I should I also don't have my smoke on
the mountain okay we have a question
from brian storm'
can you change outfits in this game I'm
assuming no no you can't yeah okay so I
missed my crossbow like the pro that I
am and now they're on to me I'm also not
in a bush so I'm just gonna oh I think
it's very much like that Fight Club
approach that Tyler Durden was talking
about like having one that's like
leather suit or you know like ready when
one pair of leather clothing that will
last you your entire lifetime yeah he's
like a cartoon character can you try the
cars I don't believe so the game is very
much right you loot you can loot the
cars for scrap and parts to improve and
repair your motorcycle Deacon is he's
all about the choppa honey your blams
you can also get air filters off of cars
to use as silencers which make picking
people off super easy because then
people don't hear your gunshots which I
got one of those going in the my time
spent with the game muscles meaty bees
both oh I love jams I think right into
their like their spine
Seymour your upper spine can you hunt
for food I have not done it myself but
I'm assuming it like absolutely because
like the you know there's wolves and
animals that you can every animal you
kill you can get me off of them you
don't actually eat it yourself but you
sell it to the kitchens at the camps for
money pretty much boom and just like
that yes the stealth is impressive I was
you know it's funny as probably just
because of that other game I've been
playing a lot that other stealth based
game that recently came out oh yeah that
was the weather thing like if it's
raining it muffles your footsteps more
so you can actually like run without
them detecting you because the whole
time I was like crouched walking up to
them which lessens it but if I was
running they'd hear me and they'll turn
around and then I can't assassinate them
myself effect that is great it feels
like a game that is really going to
reward strategy because you can come up
with a bunch of different types of
strategies like I say if you have the
ammo and the right weapons you can just
go guns blazing and so there throw a
bunch of Molotov and burn them up that
was that was my only approach that I I
guess that I ever have is just barrel on
through bold and direct eventually you
won't be able to get silencers for like
the rifles and stuff like that which
makes it even more fun to like stay far
away from an ambush camp and just pick
people off one by one
that's honestly I mean if I was actually
in a zombie apocalypse that would be my
strategy always as far away as possible
yes well that actually comes up to our
hour of gameplay already I mean we did
just clear that ambush camp we we
totally cleared we you got like seven
out of nine I just came in from us to
you okay okay yeah we did we totally did
team effort over I believe we only got
to play it for an hour I know I mean all
you guys got to see was that hour of
gameplay you also did not get to see the
introductions the beginning you
cut-scenes either which are beautiful
and gorgeous the story you know even
from the start very very real
like it hit me in the heartstrings like
for sure there's so much I want to say
what I can't yeah it's very impressive
you know opening to the game and I think
a lot of great systems working together
that will you know reward strategy days
gone days gone that is coming out this
Friday April 26 there's also a ton of
really awesome pre-order bonuses so go
ahead and go to you know the website and
check that out and try to snag some of
it because you're gonna need every bit
of help you can get and some of those
bonuses you know level up your bike and
you don't make other things probably
much more easier than it's gonna be
without it so make sure you get on that
to you guys
if you if you need to if you need that
extra you know help that's fine I guess
I'm just gonna say I think we can all
use all to helping get in this game
because it is real it's deadly gonna
give you a challenge but you know that's
a beautiful thing about it yeah I for me
I would do it for the dynamic
PlayStation 4 themes because I think
you're like three of them don't you and
one of them one of the sets yeah yes or
at least in three of the packages
there's definitely a theme in each one
so okay go check that out you guys it's
been awesome
this stream was sponsored by days gone
i'm persia this is man versus game and
we'll catch you guys next time on game
spotlight thanks for having me guys
bye